boots has improved on since he was a  younger player couldn't shoot it well a  youngster  [Applause]  did he stepped up to the challenge watch  his changes to the left  Nana's trying to dunk it in over alum  and Allen's got an incredible reach  great timing great shot blocker one year  at the University poll reached great  timing great shot blocker one year at  the University of Lakers get it up the  floor in a hurry  James push the pace big old black by  Jared Allen all of it he got all of that  ball there was no dispute right there  Lakers get it in push shot kuzmic push  the pace big old black by Darren Allison  now Blake Griffin operates against  Harris tried to jam it he's enough to  try and he got it done hey here's good  timing hands on ball excellent  three-point line getting some benefit  from their penetration  [Applause]